I
okay so are things that we've been
seeing in this workshop about 16
representations of data primarily from a
from a computational point of view you
have lots of data you have to compress
it and you want to maintain the small
finger prints sketches what have you 22
to represent the data and you can do you
know things homomorphic earlier
otherwise on it but what I'd like to
talk about today is the issue of
maintaining if you wish succinctness and
locality for a completely different
reason altogether from the point of view
of data analysis so this talk is going
to be it's about a joint work with my
this is jointly my student pressure
Andromeda was somewhere in the audience
here it's it's it's it's it's partly an
attempt to sort of lay out some nuke but
I think our new questions in in how we
do data analysis and so there will be
hopefully it'll be some interesting
questions at the end for people to
discuss so it starts off with you know
your classic mining pipeline right so
you have you know lots of data you you
clean it you know something like ninety
percent of war your work is basically
data cleaning you clean clean clean and
then you you do some exploration with
the data you may be bringing other kinds
of data you build some models you do
something at the end you declare that no
you can go on this plane today because
you're on the no-fly list or something
like that and the it when we when we
look at how to design algorithms for
doing learning of various kinds and in
the Big Data boot camp we've seen there
are many different ways of thinking
about this from a computer science point
of view we know you say okay give me a
cost function I will optimize the heck
out of it I'll just you know get you the
best approximation or I'll try to get
optimal go do what I can with it if
you're if you're doing from a
statistical perspective we're trying to
get a good estimator you're trying to do
minimax bounds in the estimated you're
trying to get something reasonably high
quality for this problem that you want
to solve and there are you know many
ways you can go over doing this we've
seen a lot of work on how to do this but
all of these methods or most of them for
the most part look at some kind of
global optimum they want to look at some
global optimization and they want to
solve that well and that's all very well
except that you know if you are the
person who's being mined in some sense
if your data is the data being mined
then it is not of any great consolation
to you that the algorithm works
awesomely if you're the one being pushed
off a plane for example or if you're the
one whose medical records are are not
being relayed property or other
on whose diagnosis is not quite correct
in other words while there the goal of
trying to give results for learning
algorithms that have global quality is a
valid goal in an interesting goal there
is also this question of locality and
this question of locality has become
even more important as the the results
of search have become more personalized
I think everyone you know knows that all
of your searches and all of the things
you do are very personalized now you get
results targeted to you if you have your
google web history turned on it gives
you results targeted to you if you go to
Amazon it gives you recommendations for
you and if you talk to people who you
know do these kinds as what's the big
companies they do they spend most of the
time doing personalized search doing
personalized mind they don't looks for
the global solution to look for local
things and so one thing that would be
nice to have is a way to say well I have
made this inference on this collection
of data I have made in particular
inference for any Chris possible point
let's say I have a classification
algorithm I've labeled a point as being
on one set of the other of the divide
how sure am I of that decision how
conferring tomayto this is actually a
good answer for that point and not
overall overall it might be great and so
that's so that you know they're there
are beans sort of examples of doing this
kind of thing in the past one very good
example of this I think is that goes
back to classification so of course you
all know if you have a classifier the
goal of classification you want to have
some kind of decision boundary that
separates points labeled plus from
points label- in the easiest case you
have some kind of linear classifier and
you have some description of the
boundary in this case a hyperplane some
kind of W X plus B it tells you how to
decide plus or minus but once you do
that in a new point arrives how do you
know how reliable your answer is of
course there are many simple you could
say I'll look at the margin with
classifier I'll see how far i am from
the margin and that gives me some clue
so I I measure the distance to my
hyperplane I'm five units away from it
okay what does that mean what does it
mean to be five or ten or fifteen units
away so there's been some work on this a
number of researchers looked at you know
how to derive some meaningful
information from this classification
boundary with the proviso that you
didn't want to actually necessarily put
the problem of modeling us into this you
could actually you know come up with a
probabilistic model you could you could
build a model and with the
classification with that but suppose I
guess gave you classified
right suppose a person large public I
say here's my classifier and you want to
in some sense post facto figure out what
might be reasonable for this so this is
technical plat scaling that comes from a
John Platt I think from 1999 and what he
said was that okay you give me a
classifier what i will do was he sort of
looked at a number of different data
sets and he said okay what what it looks
like is that you're having some kind of
sigmoid behavior around the decision
boundary especially if it's a good
decision boundary so let me try to fit a
sigmoid to this data so in particular
given my classifier given a data point
what I want to estimate is the
probability that my label is equal to 1
given the point and so I'm going to say
ok I will model this by some kind of
sigmoid and I will try to fit these
parameters capital n capital be given
some training data and what you end up
with is this conditional probably and of
course then the parameters are estimated
by the way using maximum likelihood or
whatever so what this does is it
converts a classifier a global result
that is optimized some function using
hinge loss or whatever have you into a
number for any point that says how
likely is this point to be correctly
classified or how how strong is my
belief in the answer I'm giving for this
point okay so what I want to talk about
today is doing is an attempt to do
something similar in a setting where it
gets a little bit harder to do in
unsupervised setting where you don't
really have that much label information
and in particular I'd like to do is for
clustering so of course you know
everyone knows what clustering is the
goal is to group things in a different
clusters and there are a gazillion
different kinds of clashing albums every
year you know I think they're at least
conservatively 10,000 new papers and
clustering maybe 20,000 don't know I
mean I probably have to review half of
them so it's it so so there you know
this came in this game etoys there's a
hierarchical spectral you at give it a
favorite thing and you can take all
kinds of permutations and combinations
these put them in string you know you
have a string of clustering words you
but when you get your answer how do you
know that this answer is actually any
good because clustering is one of those
annoying problems where if for the most
part it's unsupervised you just it's
it's usually an exploratory technique
you say okay I will take my data it will
cluster it and I will get some answer
and I not always sure what the answer is
because I don't always have a nice model
you know I'm not doing say for example
learning a mixture of gaussians I'm not
doing LD and not doing something
well defined probabilistic model behind
what I'm doing I'm just clustering some
data and so I do need to know how good
my answer is and as a consequence
there's been a number of efforts to try
and understand the quality of clustering
algorithms so be a whole lot of work on
this so for example there's a whole I
mean again there's a bunch of work on
this but they can roughly fit into three
or four different categories one is this
thing called internal validation if I
have a cluster if I have a clustering a
good plus ring is one where clusters are
tight and they're far right so you can
actually quantify this you can say okay
tightness is the width of a cluster far
as the inter-cluster distance take some
ratio you can do things like this you
can say okay this is the measure of how
good the clusterings you can also things
like external validation if you actually
have a reference some kind of reference
clustering some kind of ground through
some amount of data that you actually
have checked then you can do something
called external validation you compare
to the ground truth this actually brings
up a whole separate story or be the
geometry of the space of clusterings how
you compare clusterings what are
appropriate distance functions and so
and so forth and there's a lot of work
on that is true and there's also this
thing which is often called relative
validation which say is ok I for me like
k-means I want to figure if my answer is
good and so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to run it a bunch of times look at
the different answers and see how
different they are from each other and
if I keep getting the same answer over
again I feel more confident that this is
a good answer and this brings up another
topic which is related all this is whole
issue of stability in clustering how do
you figure out if a clustering answers
table there's been some work from people
here on various notional stability for
example you might say are posturing is
stable if I put her if I when I perturb
points a little bit I don't change the
answer too much or a clustering is
stable is when if I know there's a good
answer I can find it efficiently if
there's an answer that's known to be
close to the good answer in a kind of a
Hamming sense there's been a bunch of
works on that but all of these methods
again our global methods they give you
kind of a global view of where the
clustering is working and again in this
in this sort of more personalized view
of how we look at data we want something
too short certificate for a point that
says this was my label for this
clustering and i'm pretty sure that this
is a good lately or i have some
confidence based on what I'm doing that
this is a good labeled so this is the
prob
I give you an arbitrary clustering of
data preferably I know nothing what
where it came from in the most general
case I may know something about the
distance space is defined on and I want
to be able to assign some kind of
confidence bound two points in the
clustering or even new points i come up
i want to say okay you know this yes
this point is assigned us cluster but i
only have this much conference in doing
so and i want something that has a kind
of a notion of scale within these
numbers that zeta independent maybe it's
a probability or something like that it
should be agnostic as far as possible to
how i generally clustering again this
whole idea of having a data pipeline in
a pipeline you don't always have control
over where your data comes from so if
it's presented to you you'd like to be
able to work with what you have it
should work given a single clustering
I'm not talking about a moral or non
Samba lime juice of a single clustering
but I should build a have it should be
general enough I can use it to compare
different costumes if I need to it
should be very specific to one thing so
this is kind of the goals I said of
course since you know I wrote these four
points and I want to hit them all on by
but but these are also reasonable things
if you'd like to have okay and one a
minor point this question since it
always comes up and maybe some of you
are thinking about this i'll bring it up
right now and there's this whole this
whole area what is called outlier
detection and it sounds very similar to
this it's like oh they're these points
and are good points i want to find a
find out which points are not good and
they live with them an outlier detection
in the theory world at least as a
standard way to think about some of
these questions you can say i have a
collection of points i want to find an
optimal clustering and i'm allowed to
throw away an epsilon fractional points
in machine learning other side you can
have a misclassification error you can
have some small point set of points or
misclassified that's okay but you don't
have too many points misclassified this
is one way of capturing outliers so
there are more regular eyes days of
doing this as well you don't have to
have this hard thing I take it or don't
take it but out lie detection is subtly
different from this kind of problem in
the sense that even an outlier detection
problem you don't want outliers because
they really mess up your cost function
usually especially in El to say and
sable just big wart may pull things out
like crazy so if you do all kinds of
work to make sure they got in part of
your cost function but they don't
necessarily change the assignment itself
usually they're outliers to a single
cluster you're probably going to put
them in the same cluster anyway but they
just messing up your cross function
affect your algorithm whereas with
things like the problem of validation
the problem of finding a certificate for
a label it is quite possible that the
cost does not change very
much but the label does and because a
label is kind of a more of binary thing
that can change the decisions don't
dream quite a bit so you do want to know
to what degree the slaves they are
slightly different in some way I will
also talk about probabilistic modeling a
little later on that's another area
where you think okay if I have a
probabilistic model like getting these
beliefs values automatically from the
mixture of gaussians or what have you
that's a more specialized set ok any
questions so far it's all very high
level I know so I'll get some technical
details in a bit but so again just to
remind you all the goal is to given a
clustering of points find some kind of
confidence numbers that were a number
that's attached to every or set of
numbers or a vector that's attached to
any single point they give you some
sense of how reliable this clustering is
with respect to the data or how
trustworthy your labels are that point
ok and the idea that we're going to use
is this general notion of an idea
regional influence and so the core idea
which will try to formalize in a bit is
that in some sense things have read some
influence clusters have regions of
influence they may own a certain portion
of the space and that's why you
partition things and so a point should
be in a cluster if the point treated as
a cluster by itself had a region of
influence that kind of overlapped a
cluster you want to put it in so what
does that mean it seems a bit vague so
in particular let's take an example
actually don't even read this so suppose
I have points in the line of the easy
case freedom clustering points online
and I have these clusters and the color
resolution is not as nice as I should've
made it but there are four clusters here
for the four points there's a blue a red
a light blue dark blue cluster there and
so you now you get a point coming in and
you would like to know you know where
should this point B and what kind of
confidence do I have that this points
label is in the audience so I probably
want to put this in what I'll call the
red cluster for now and what I want to
say is that if i look at now what this
point would be like if it were a
separate cluster all by itself it would
be in something stealing some mass from
the red cluster are quite a bit of it in
fact and stealing a little bit of mass
lublu gloucester so it is stealing
volume from the red cluster a lot of it
and so it is much more likely to be
associated with the Red Lobster that's
the rough idea here and so in some of
course what they're doing given Easter
and I say area or volume on rocky
talking about distances I'm saying the
distance to their to the red center the
center of a cluster is much less than
the distance to any other center and so
that is going to increase its its
likelihood of being in the red Center
and then if you if you look at for
example a lot of these mixture model
learning so if it's mixture the
gaussians army general Bregman
divergences what you see is that the
resulting algorithms the assignment
probability of a point to a cluster
looks exactly like this it says the
probability of assigning a point to a
particular Gaussian is roughly eat ooh
the minus distance L true distance
squared between the point and the center
of the current Royd if it's some other
general Bregman divergence it's e to the
minus the Bragman divergence between the
point and the center of the cluster so
this idea of using distances is actually
it shows up in many clustering
algorithms are ready but distances are
not quite enough I mean distances
capture a little bit of what you would
like to see this problem they don't
capture everything there they capture in
some sense of one-dimensional rendition
of what you want because it just lines
in general you could have a clustering a
bunch of points don't worry about those
lines for now I'll explain that means
MIT and if i have a new point q I could
measure the distances to three different
cluster centers the CC prime of the sea
star and I could make some sense oh you
know it's so far from this it's so from
that this is maybe the ratio in which it
should be assigned to three clusters but
of course that's very unlikely to happen
most of the time if you run a clustering
with a different random scenes you want
to try and assign Q to Z star because of
this kind of shielding effect that it
has and what the saying is that there's
some kind of spatial structure that
you'd like to exploit to try to
understand where a point should go and
what it's true label should be so if we
develop that further we get to what we
want to do so again there's this
property of clustering is called the
Warner property again I don't know
probably most of you already the
audience know about Voronoi diagrams and
the Warner property but just just in
case there's a few you don't a voronoi
diagram is the partition of space if I
have a bunch of points it's a partition
of space so that each cell of the
partition
one of those points is the nearest
neighbor once called so called the post
office from so in this particular
partition if you look at the point of
the bottom there that cell around it any
point in that cell will declare this to
be its nearest neighbor now clusterings
many clustering algorithms yield a
clustering that has what is called the
Voronoi property namely that for any
particular point the cluster you want to
assign it to is in fact its nearest
neighbor so the clustering is induce a
partition of the space and this property
gets used a lot when doing clustering
faidley's to efficient algorithms and so
on so forth so can we use this property
of clustering this sort of natural
property of class things to actually
define this notion of volume capture and
so the idea here is that suppose I have
three points okay so these three points
and their three clusters there and I
formed this born a diagram so it would
look something like this okay and now a
new point comes in the new point comes
in here i will now pretend this new
point was a cluster by itself construct
the resulting new voronoi diagram and it
looks like this and now look at this
voronoi cell of this point very
carefully what essentially is done it
has stolen volume from the three voronoi
cells that you already have so in
particular if you look at the this
volume here you can say that this volume
is divided at these three parts for
these three cultures as well with and so
you can define this ratio of the ratio
of say this volume are three to the
overall volume of the cell and this is
in some sense the amount of volume that
that point has stolen from the cluster C
3 and so on so forth in general for each
point you get this vector will call this
the affinity vector and it's a
fractional area stolen from it and this
of courses of its of a point or simplex
the values onto one so this will define
as this the vector of affinities that
will we will now sort of use as our
coding if you wish to to understand the
affinity of points or clusters so the
couple of interesting properties this
this idea was first used back in the 80s
so in the in the area of GIS this was
used to do interpolation and so they're
the problem was I give you a bunch of
points and they have scalar values i
would like to interpolate a function
between them and i don't want to put any
modeling assumptions later I don't
really know whether what
function is that would appropriately fit
so this idea of natural neighbor
interpolation says for each point in the
domain in the in the convex hull of
these points you will get a vector of
affinities just the way I described by
computing the wanted diagram inserting
the point in looking how much area at
steeles those weights that that convex
count the convex vector this vector sums
to one is used to compute a convex
combination of the weights of all the
points involved in this and that gives
you an interpolant and it's interpolant
as various nice properties it's
continuous it's it's differentiable
except at the data points and it's me in
this and it's variants have been used a
lot in the GIS community so that's where
this first comes from back in the 80s
and so what we're going to use here is
mainly just the vectors observer not
going to Ackley do any interpolation
just using the vectors of these of these
ratios and you know you can make a
couple of observations if a point you
know none you can never have two values
that are more than point five so you
have one value that's more than point
five that's in some sense the strongest
assignment and there's some so the
maximum affinity value you have is also
a scalar function is also a useful proxy
for this entire vector it could also
take the entropy of the entire vector
since it is a you can act like a
distribution it gives you some measure
of the skew like the the more spread out
the points assignments are the higher
the entropy will be and therefore the
lower it's your confidence will be in
its assignment so their various things
you can do with this and so that's the
basic idea the basic idea has use this
this geometric structure of the space
and of the clusterings to define this
notion of infinity four points okay and
it has the advantage of being you know
relatively easy to visualize you can you
take a bunch of points up there you can
draw a nice contour maps you can do
things like students you can do this
contour maps to show you where regions
of high instability or a low-affinity
are and you can again see it's okay
there's some region here which is very
unstable because you're not quite sure
where this point should go and so on so
forth this is not necessary the best
visualization the world but it shows you
you could visualize these things with
the scalar functions over ok so but this
is not really enough in some sense
because you often have a notion of
importance for a clustering you have
weights you have density functions when
you say ok this cluster is some or
bigger than that it's got more points in
it you'd like to be able to capture that
as well
and so it turns out the important
property that you want to keep is that
this volunteer Graham has polyhedral
cells because we'll need that later for
computations and so you want to make
sure that everything stays polyhedral
and so the very nice structure from
computational geometry that generalizes
the idea of Voronoi diagram it's called
a power diagram just like in a regular
phone a diagram you have this distance
function and this is used to construct
the boundaries basically the boundary of
any voronoi cell is the place where
these two things become equal so d PX is
equal to DP why where this is the
distance function you can do the same
thing in this sense where you now
essentially shift things up and down by
a weight function and internally what
this is saying is that if the weight of
us point is large then the effective
distance to it is less so you can reach
out and grab things that are much
further away and so that's what you get
there you get this these larger circle
the circle the radius denotes the weight
and so now this point is pushing out in
grabbing things where that line should
have really been here it's actually back
there the good thing about the power
diagram is that it guarantees polyhedral
cells you get another you get another
diagram that has in the lines or hyper
planes you don't get curved objects if
you remove for example the square root L
square just in a regular that just the
Euclidean distance minus the weight you
get these curved parabolic arcs and
that's not nice to do with so I just
wreck technical people so once you do
that again you can do things like this
you can say for example again we had our
familiar cuanto diagram we all these
points you had these regions of high
instability in the middle here and now
if I suddenly increase the density
there's no longer much ambiguity about
where you should cluster points that
whole region of uncertainty just goes
away you only retain some other portions
of it so using the density function you
can actually capture a little bit more
about how your uncertainty would how
these things on this generalizes to
other spaces if you're clustering with
Bregman divergences you they all have a
very similar structure it's sort of well
it's known that for Bregman divergences
the appropriate Voronoi diagrams also
are linear if you define them in the
correct direction and so you can do the
same trick there this in some sense it
works in the sense you can define this
with kernels but I'm not going to talk
about kernels mothers are the technical
difficulties in computing these things
with kernels but you can get the same
section so in so this notion is somewhat
general you can care you can capture
many different kinds of classes of
distance from
which is good because your cluster using
come from different sources okay so how
do you compute these fairy directives so
it turns out in low dimensions this is
relatively easy in two dimensions for
example you can compute a warrant a gram
in que la que time you can intersect two
convex polygons which is what you need
to do to get these share regions to
compute the volume of a polygon you want
to triangulate it because once you
triangulate it you can each triangle
takes constant time to compute the area
for and you can triangle eight a polygon
of size K in linear time so things are
pretty easy so over if you have a query
point in roughly k log a time where k is
the number of clusters you can compute
an answer in 3d gets a little bit harder
the Voronoi diagram itself is bigger
it's of size K squared and so that's the
dominant term in all the calculations
the rest of them are still a little easy
to do but that because of that K squared
time you pay that much time per query of
course all this breaks in high
dimensions once you go to D dimensions
the Warren diagram of D dimensions is
roughly k to the D over 2k the ceiling
of the over two so now these things
really work you can't actually expect to
compute any of these things in higher
dimensions so what do you do of course
the answer is to approximate you want to
get some kind of approximate estimate of
what these affinities are again and
again the goal is to get the small
certificate for each point that gives
you some sense of where it's true
cluster centers are so what do I want to
do what I wanted was given some epsilon
parameter some epsilon greater than 0 I
would like to find some approximate if
any vector that has a small L infinity
distance from the true of any vector and
there's a very easy way to think about
this problem that basically what I'd
like to do a sample suppose I can sample
a point from the Voronoi cell of P I
find it second closest neighbor of
course is close to neighborhoods be so
find a single neighbor increment the
counter the neighbor and do this over
and over again at the end I get a bunch
of counsel I normalize them and of
course it's easy to process each sample
to make this decision you just have two
questions to answer how many samples do
you need and how do you sample from the
Warner's a low point so the first part
is again relatively easy the standard
sampling tricks you can do do this I
mean basically something like 1 over
epsilon squared samples will suffice if
you can sample uniformly from the war
neck so you can get an answer for this
and there it'll be within this error
bound the standard
epsilon sampling VC dimension type
arguments or even another way but the
second part is it's a little bit you
know a little bit takes a little bit
more thought how do you sample them the
Warner cell of a point again remember a
point high dimensions one thing we do
know is that it's you it devour my cell
is a convex body its convex and it has
an easy membership Oracle because all i
have to do is check these k points to
sort of see is it closer to that point
than to any of them so that part is easy
and luckily we do there have been a long
line of work and the people is room like
some potions who've done a lot of work
on this if i give you a convex body in
high dimensions and i want to sample
from it uniformly how do i and i'm all
i'm given as a membership oracle how do
i do this and so there's a whole long
series of results starting from you know
the early clue the classic by by dire
freeze in Condon which which rarely
containers right here and i think ruffle
was the original algorithm run something
like d to the 26 time and then right now
i think this is if i'm not mistaken the
best phone possible under some
conditions and you need ye to the fourth
samples from to get it is your fault
sorry oracle calls to get a uniform
sample from the and in fact this works
for other distributions as well not just
uniform distributions many other kinds
of distributions this algorithm is
somewhat complicated in practice you can
do something a little simpler and this
has this this is nice method called
hitman sampling it's it's a very nice
trick I thought I'll just sort of
mention here for people who may not know
about this and the way it works is
basically you you have your convex set
you take a point you choose a random
direction and you extend out to the
boundary can do this file bisection
search using the membership Oracle and
then choose a random point along that
boundary and then repeat again and so
this this process actually can with
appropriate conditions on you know where
you are in the beginning can be shown to
converge very quickly and in practice it
actually works operate well take to get
a sense okay one final trick so far all
I've described as a sampling procedure
that will be polynomial in the dimension
which is ok but it's still not great but
it turns I don't even need that so let's
limit ourselves to you clear distance
for now so the K clusters induce a sort
of a cable k minus 1 dimensional
subspace and there's this general kind
of folklore of thought in clustering
that if you have data that's cake
all the action is happening in K
dimensions there's really nothing
interesting happening outside it right
and there's some there's some formal
results along these lines this is a
general kind of feeling and so here
again you can formalize this you can say
look you know if I'm measuring say you
claim distance squared you can be
composed it into the component along the
subspace the component orthogonal
subspace and now if you look at the
Voronoi diagram that you get it
basically consists of our nor of a
rewarding diagram in the kth subspace
with extrusions outwards uniform
extrusions outwards so from a volume
sampling point of view you don't
actually care about you can actually
slice the space down and just sample in
that space so this likely means that
your effective dimensionality is only k
it's not deep and so this improves the
bond you get that so to summarize you
are if you're given a clustering and you
want any of a query p you can and and i
should point out that none of this
depends on the number of points that you
had cluster in the first place only
depends on K and epsilon and not even
the dimension of space at least for
Euclidean distances so you project the
clusters to a k-dimensional space you
sample uniformly compute these
frequencies and you just return the
approximate Phineas cooks and again the
running time is pauline k 1 r epsilon
and there you know in practice actually
runs very quickly good order
milliseconds per query so what I'd like
to do is since I've you know I'm and
claiming a couple of things I'm claiming
that first of all this problem is
interesting and that secondly that this
approach is a way to get at the idea of
a local of local certificates for points
that you in some way by doing this weird
thing here you can actually get at a
sense of how reliable a clustering label
is for a point so in order to convince
you of this that but probably only way
to convince you is to sort of maybe show
you a number of different experiments
you can run so say okay look this seems
like a right thing that seems like it's
doing the right thing is by no means
conclusive this is sort of early stages
of what we're thinking about here but
there is some initially encouraging
evidence that suggests that this might
be a reasonable thing to do so for those
of you work in machine learning you
probably know what this is is the
amnesty debase it's a database of digits
basically all clustered and labels it's
nice to play with and it's being played
with to death and what you can basically
you get the data it's labeled in one of
ten different clusters or different
digits and their images in the go
to cluster them or do something with
them are built classifiers or what you
want and so here's a little experiment
where we took an arbitrary clustering
just run k-means or something else on
this and then computed the the affinity
scores and the max affinity which is
will call the stability for different
clusters okay for different points and
then took points that had high stability
and points at a low stability and
actually took a random sample from the
top 10% Louis ten percent so we didn't
really buy us one and so this what you
get if you get the fuzziness here by
there is just in the resolution on the
screen these are the images the way they
are if you look at points that are
highly stable what you actually get is
what you expect you get points that are
fairly clear this is a zero 649 and
they're reasonably clear as far as
possible bus data and if you look at
points that are highly unstable again
without knowing how the clustering
happened and just by running the
stability you get points that are a lot
more ambiguous now is this a 0 is this
kind of a 6 or is it a zero with a
little line attached to it this for this
9 look almost similar and so on so forth
so in sometimes you can see that you
know that that there is a least a
correlation between the numbers you're
computing via this affinity calculation
which is completely oblivious to be out
to the data are just looking at the
geometry of the data and the actual
answer is just seen from this another
interesting application where this we're
looking at affinity scores becomes
interesting is in what are we calling
active cluster what I can call active
lusting what people have looked at and
the idea is that in many problems what
you'd like to do is since you have a lot
of data you would like to subsample the
data to solve your problem but you it's
not always obvious how to subsample the
data to get things irrelevant especially
for things like clustering and so some
more if you could if I knew that there
were points that I wanted to pick that
we're deciding in forming the true
decision boundary much like how active
learning works I would want to pick
those points first and that's in some
sense what these affinity scores allow
you to do they allow you to they allow
you to quickly so you for example you
can run a very quick k-means plus plus
type clustering initialization get some
very crude clustering compute the
affinity scores of the spectra crude
clustering and then sample points based
on the affinity scores in other words
take points some points that have low
low affinity which give you the skeleton
of the data and take some points that
have high in free to give you the core
and it turns out that something very
very few points and again it's all the
empirical
don't have formal bones for this you can
actually get clusters clusterings that
are equivalent in quality and you can
get them much faster so in some sense
what you're getting with this affinity
calculation is a kind of a skeleton of
the data the relevant skeleton for
decision boundaries not a corset per se
but a skeleton of some kind and in fact
we have ongoing work with Killian
Weinberger from washu on speeding of
other kinds of classification algorithms
the transductive SVM other methods using
the same idea and we have some very
promising results there as well another
place where these scores are useful is
in doing model selection again one of
the biggest thorny issues in clustering
is this whole problem model selection
and again if you have a you know if you
either have a probabilistic model or if
you have some criteria like the AIC or
the bi c or other insert letter name IC
criterion you can try to determine what
the right number of clusters are for
your problem but in general there's no
easy way to do this and basically you
stare at charts like this and you look
at oh there's a big bump somewhere and
maybe that's right and there's very
crude techniques like this and this
basically is because the cost of your
clustering always gets better you know
if you if at the end you put all your
points in a single foster by themselves
everything looks great and that's why
you need to regularize in some form and
so there are many regularization ways of
dealing with this so one thing that's a
fish that's interesting with looking the
severity scores that the affinity scores
don't necessarily decree keep increasing
or decreasing monotonically as you
partition your clustering the if you
look at the cluster which is very good
and you split it the stability of these
points just goes down a lot because now
we are not I'm confused as to where to
put them I could go one way or the other
and so if you actually look at plotting
the average stability of a point set as
you change the number of clusters you
start seeing these peaks which hopefully
not coincidentally exactly match the
true number of clusters in these data
sets which are kind of gives us that we
know of in our ground toward innocence
here so again there's some hint maybe
that you know you can use a local
structuring of stability in an aggregate
sense to get a global sense of what the
clustering looks like even though there
are other methods as well to do that but
this gives you both local and the global
at the same time so there's number of
questions about this I mean a lot of
this work is very sort of exploratory
with learning to understand exactly
what's going on here and whether there's
any formal way of explaining all these
things
so in particular can you correlate these
affinity scores with the probabilities
you extract from out from a same model
and so one experiment that we had done
was to say okay let's for example run an
e/m type algorithm I try to learn a
mixture gaussians and look at the soft
cloth the soft assignments you get four
clusters and compare that to the
affinity scores you get here and in many
different examples what we found was
that there was a very very high
correlation between the vectors you got
from a probabilistic algorithm and
vectors you got from the score here so
again there's some evidence that these
things are capturing the right kind of
notion but again we need more more
understanding of what's going on here
another thing that we've been looking at
is you know the affinities or in the
maximum fit is define a vector or scalar
field of the data there's been a lot of
work in the computational topology
community on trying to understand how to
cluster data from a topological
perspective what of course they're
missing is are they by design in some
senses the geometric structure and along
the data they've been looking at
topological constructs and so one thing
that I mean that we're interested in is
sort of can you look at things like
persistence which are this topological
notion which is it says like a noise
removal motion that's very powerful idea
and topology to build over the scalar
field that you get from these abilities
to combine essentially geometry and
topology to understand the structure of
the data again give it the ole vain to
give these local certificates for
quality of an assignment so a more basic
algorithmic question can you compute
since we care about the skeleton these
points are low finding we compute them
quickly without having to lose over the
entire the entire set of data we care
about again we have some there are some
heuristics sort of approved as a
progressive quadtree based process you
can use to sort of progressively refine
your scalar field but they'll be nice to
have some more formal audience for you I
can get the points of stability which
are at least a little bit more something
and so and so forth and now there are
applications we've seen number of
applications I there's something I
mentioned that we have in our work that
where you can use these things to kind
of accelerate the process of clustering
and you can use it essentially as a core
set of a kind where the the points of
low affinity are your skeleton of the
decision boundaries that you can use to
solve problems other other problems
where this can be looked at and on that
note I will stop and not keep you from
your coffee anymore thank you for
listening
yes
right so the so that there are a couple
of problems with this approach first of
all the notion of stability for a
clustering itself although people have
looked at it the conclusion has been is
that it's not quite clear how to define
it some of these notions of stability
that I mentioned they are they're
problematic in certain ways so if you're
talking about this for example how the
cluster to maximize the sum of
affinities for example would be one
thing I have thought about this you
learn how to do it yet but that's
something that we thought about okay if
I said that my goal is to maximize the
sum of affinities how would I go about
doing it so it's a good question i don't
know the answer though yeah thank you